[Musique]
allez-vous nous sommes avec mamie
twinkie et françois ça lui vient une
idée géniale il m'a dit mais qui serait
drôle qu'on fasse une vidéo on essaie de
survivre
une nuit en pleine forêt avec le dal une
sorte de man vs wild improvisé et ce qui
est cool c'est que françois lui a des
capacités particulières pour survivre en
milieu hostile à ce seuil naturel c'est
bien ça ouais c'est ça c'est un peu de
ma passion c'est ce que j'aime faire
dans la vie est ce que tu as été scout
ou pas alors pas du tout nous on est
atteint le milieu d'une forêt ok c'est
pour ça casse et reibel vu on a marché
pendant de nombreuses heures en pour ça
c'est faux je suis un gros mytho
bonjour je viens pour la petite heure
une petit à petit à petit en est c'est
fou ça m'a épuisé totalement on vient
d'arriver je suis très content et on va
pouvoir commencer à survivre en milieu
hostile
pour cette première étape ne vont
trouver un endroit où construire notre
habitat un endroit plat on risque pas de
rouler ou de chuter pendant notre
sommeil ce qui serait une chose terrible
et on va construire au dessus nos à
l'aide de branches de mousse de feuilles
un vrai abri pour pas se prendre de la
pluie dans la nuit parce qu'il pleut en
fait aujourd'hui pendant que je parle je
gagne du temps car mes collègues sont en
train de faire le boulot et je ne les
aide pas ne partez jamais avec moi en
pleine nature est un délit travail alors
vous avez parfait bas la première étape
a été faite finalement sans mon aide
c'est un petit trépied qu'on va
construire non au tir et c'est simple
voilà on va construire un petit répit on
se doit c'est l'électricité au niveau de
cet arbre juste là c'était ça on
s'allonge les gars luca toni place très
tôt dans la gauche à droite
tu préfères cette mauvaise herbe ou
cette brindille au quai albert je veux
juste pour cette équipe parce que j'ai
pas trouvé de me salir ça vous dérange
pas je suis archi gare donc voilà on
sera longue de tous les trois comme ça
donc on met le pied derrière nous ok
mais ça me touche pardo cette place est
assez conforme je suis content il est
l'heure de la deuxième étape
là il faut qu'on prévoit un trépied pour
accrocher la poutre qu'on va accoucher
d'un côté sur un arbre de l'autre côté
sur le trépied
on ramène on rapatrie les sacs pour
établir le camp de ben 10 excellent
on est bien tout seul on sort on va je
peux pas l'aider à ses partisans
[Musique]
en dessous je t'en prie on va le tirer
en mode celui-là il va venir vers moi
c'est un échec
l'une des trois branches a cédé sous le
poids elle était un peu trop morte voilà
c'est pour ça qu'il faut trouver des
branches qui sont pas mortes sinon elles
sont trop fragilisée elle se pète c'est
pas pour autant qu'il faut arracher des
branches des arbres attention à
n'utiliser que du bois qui est déjà au
sol
allez deuxième essai ce parti
[Musique]
je l'aide peut-être je m'amuse mais les
français en souffrance balance quand tu
peux refaire comme tout à l'heure c'est
à dire je vais me lever et tu vas passer
là avec plaisir rien ça avec ap par
contre tu arrêtes de l'accord dans la
tête ça fait deux mois
[Musique]
incroyable voilà et on a un truc et on a
un truc c'est alors on peut toujours pas
faire de podcasts dans nature
malheureusement mais on peut dormir en
forêt il est fatigué blague à part il
faut finir l'étape 2 en gros on a créé
un support ont du coup on a une branche
qui tient à l'horizontale à 1 mètre 80
du sol et maintenant il va falloir foot
les branches qu'il ya ici de long de
celle qui à l'horizontale et ensuite
recouvrir le tout de feuilles de
brindilles de d'être de cadavres de
plein de choses diverses et variées pour
nous protéger des intempéries
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
papa pas je suis dans l'abri
actuellement est franchement good job
parce que il est privé mais qu'at il est
bien isolé on est une petite odeur
naturelle de verdure je sens qu'on va
bien dormir un sas assure on a une
pierre à feu ok à laquelle on va frotter
en veut qu'on a trouvé dans la foi
vraiment beaucoup de chance on est
obligé d'avoir un minimum de matos avec
nous quoi cela n'empêche la difficulté
ça va être de trouver du bois qui peut
s'embraser donc du bois sec et là il a
plus de ouf
donc tout est parfaitement humide donc
en gros on est obligé de choper du bois
épais pour le coupé et chopper
l'intérieur qui lui est sec pour avoir
des bûches toute la soirée moi mon
travail ça va être de faire exactement
comme je viens de faire là un mini abri
pour pouvoir suspendre les bus chassa au
dessus du feu et qu'elle commet du bois
sec à volonté et à faire à travailler on
va faire ça vous angoisse parti et 2
aucun autre au bout de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh [ __ ] ça marche bien tu vois merci
[ __ ] je suis fier de moi c'est comme
si j'avais un enfant c'est parti bien
sûr pour faire un trépied d'une qualité
extrême qui va impressionner françois
besoin de vérité je relève le deuxième
très piègeux réussi ma mission jusqu'au
bout
est ce que françois ce soir à saint
pierre de moi mais normalement j'ai fait
ce qu'il faut tu vois normalement jusqu
en fait j'ai joué à the forest et du
coup ça tient les comptes en francs soit
[Musique]
ça va tomber qu'est ce qui va tomber sur
mes acquis va tomber du coup là on va
pouvoir poser les choses ici au dessus
du peu pour que ça sèche j'ai réussi ma
mission
françois a quasiment terminé de réparer
le bois pour le feu et florian a
terminées l'isolation est un [ __ ] de
votre travail de l'équipe y est gay mais
on est tellement des gros nolife qu'on
arrive à l'abri au seul mètre carré où
il ya de la 3g de toute la forêt aux
designers arrête ça parce qu'un bon
voilà je suis super bien
[Musique]
les amis la nuit est en train de tomber
et nous allons enfin allumés ce fichu
feu qui est l'étape la plus récente
pourquoi parce que si on n'arrive pas à
lui mais on mange pas ce soir ici on a
vraiment de quoi faire sécher des bûches
on a plein de bois vous avez fait un
tacle monstrueux rien ne pourrait être
plus satisfaisant que de réussir allumer
le feu est-ce que vous êtes prêts les
gars allez vas-y [ __ ] c'était sur les
gars
et gare à l'égard des gars à apprendre à
apprendre à la une toile une toile doit
bébé oil & gas j'ai allumé le premier
feu de ma vie enfin je veux dire avec
son briquet quoi veni allumettes c'est
pas mal ce qui se passe c'est pas mal
oui ce fut à devenir adulte
c'est officiel le feu est devenu
adolescent et il sera bientôt adultes le
moment est venu de découvrir cette
fameuse côte de boeuf
elle est belle des coupes et des petits
bouche pour le morceau tellement énorme
il a vraiment dit au boucher je veux
l'animal entier s'il vous plaît est en
place elle est en place les gars on se
rapproche du but vous rendez compte de
ce qui se passe j'ai quoi s'en fout tu
attends c'est quoi ton jeu peuvent en
attente à temps vous de cette incroyable
il est temps d'inaugurer le bal puis
avoir la cuite au tchad c'est parti
parfait ouais et la viande est archi
bones est vrai que télé chez un boucher
un vrai boucher quand j'ai un truc pour
toi lucas bouche à bouche je peux pas
trois pattes roma 3 c'est faux ok
[Musique]
et
les amis nous venons de terminer notre
repas actuellement il fêterait nuit et
on a la chance d'être dans une forêt
bref j'ai proposé à florian de profiter
de ce décor incroyable finalement vous
allez venir en colonie avec nous à la
sortie cette exploration nocturne
frank esser ce faire
ok on vient de trouver une petite
qualité mais patatras fait part à mon
jeu court
le mec pourquoi c'est pas moi c'est
l'anru c'est génial c'est vraiment qu'on
a et a vu notre campement et doux qui
entoure un endroit beaucoup mieux
après peut-être moins fmc que ça
appartient en bourse on sait
parfaitement qu'elle était taillée par
mais quoi c'est la petite découverte du
soir qui nous met bien on est content
regardez comme françois est un homme bon
on rentre au campement et là surprise
les sacs de couchage sont prêts sous la
gamme anne bonjour je dors aujourd'hui
pour après la fin de ma vie entre deux
hommes les mecs marché pour cette
journée c'était cool merci autour du 15
demain réveil à quelle heure à cette
heure très bien allez bonne nuit à tous
ça me fait extrêmement mal au revoir
bonjour nous fait nous rêver il faudra
redescendre
vous êtes montagne pour aller prendre un
train ça kate est ce vrai ouais ça calme
oui ce qu'il faut savoir qu'on est en
slip dans les sacs de couchage et qu'il
faut qu'on sorte du sac de couchage
[Musique]
les amis et sauviac c'est officiellement
la fin de cette vidéo yes et qu'on va
rentrer chez nous au chaud l'évêque
c'était une [ __ ] d'expérience un peu
vraiment génial
1000mercis attaché à lui mettre debout
ce génial on doit les boys doit me
cétacés où j'avais pas fais ça depuis
des années sans j'avais pas fait ça tous
pour solo sans animateur de colonie
c'est vrai que j'ai fait j'ai 12 ans
c'est vrai que c'est assez à
l'épanouissement quoi être comme ça en
pleine nature un peu déconnecté mais pas
trop non plus qu'il faut lancer une ou
deux games heure sonne pour sentir bien
construit des trucs c'était très cool
voir qu'avec en fait juste des bouts de
bois et de la ficelle tu peux tu peux te
choper un petit abri enfin c'est
vraiment marrant comme la piste
vachement cool de tous les trous ouais
jackson il ya un mood entre potes qui
est vraiment tout c'est tellement sympa
très sympa même si non mais j'ai hyper
lui même si manu twin cup était cette
nuit savoir il a lâché 1 p 2 ou fait ça
sentait très mauvais dans l'abri en à
coude en plein air sans déconner ça que
j'adore le foot et baï magath est à
l'avant aux libyens mille merci pour
cette expérience
et puis on se retrouve
je suis pas trop plu mais on se retrouve
bientôt pour les potes dans la grotte
avec trois amis c'est vrai mais le ciel
vous a plu à les voir la chaîne vitrine
très important et la chaîne de france
moi et je vous fais un maximum de bisous
et à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo
dans mon studio
voilà est-ce que c'est une bonne foi ce
sens je suis pas sûr je suis pas
convaincu
[Musique]